the winner of the title America's Got
Talent the champions best in the world
[Music]
less than five months after being
crowned the winner of America's Got
Talent
magician Shin Lim is taking home the top
honor once again as he was named the
winner of America's Got Talent the
champions thank you so much
follow your dreams it was such an honor
he has to do back here this is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity clean
okay do you know which Queen then you
actually kiss the face of the Queen
right over there et spoke with the 27
year old magician on the red carpet at
the big finale where he admitted he got
pretty starstruck during the competition
there are literally acts from around the
world here some will have won there a
lot of my won yeah
did that add any pressure to you I think
my around for the last one there are
five first-place winners so I was just
kind of like yeah okay we'll see what
happened I think it's very humbling when
you're competing against someone like
Susan Boyle right right it's basic
sightings but it's fun yeah you know
it's full of surprises
season 14 of AGT is right around the
corner and you can expect at least one
major change ie Klum and Mel B won't be
returning to the judges panel et learned
last week they'll be replaced by
Julianne Hough and Gabrielle Union Heidi
confirmed her departure Monday night on
Twitter calling a GT quote an incredible
experience it has been absolutely
incredible that's been a love fest I
have to say because you have the best of
the best
you know performing right in front of
our very eyes you know some of my
favorites from around the world who have
heard of such a Susan Boyle you know I
was a little star you two came onto that
stage and you love doing this don't you
I do yeah sitting right in the front and
seeing one act after the next
[Music]